Hey Thoughty2 here.
This RIF will be a bit different to normal,
I recently reached 100,000 subscribers, thanks
to you guys, I couldn't have done it without
every single one of you.
Thank you for watching, liking, commenting
and sharing.
To celebrate, this RIF will be facts about
myself.
I asked you on Facebook and Twitter what you
really want to know about Thoughty2, so here
we go.
I'll start from the beginning, Kim and Matt
asked me, why did I start this channel?
For as long as I can remember I've been interested
in facts, the more useless the better.
I've always researched and asked questions,
about absolutely everything, when I come across
something in life that I don't know or understand,
I have to know... why, when, who and what's
it all about.
So a couple of years ago I thought, why don't
I share my passion for knowledge with the
world, and along the way if I can make a living
out of doing what I love, then, well isn't
that everyone's dream.
When I uploaded my first video my expectations
were low, The idea of more than 10 people
watching it seemed alien to me, I was in no
way prepared for the enormity of views that
followed over the next year.
And I still can't quite believe my good fortune.
Evan Wright asked, where do I live?
I grew up in and to this day, still live,
in a region in the north of England called
Lancashire, which is famous for bringing the
world the industrial revolution and The Beatles.
Laura and Ali asked how old am I?
Thanks for asking, I'm 22.
Morgan Jerome asked what is my favourite food.
That's a tricky question, but it's probably
Marmite on toast, it's really popular in the
United Kingdom but if you've never tasted
it before, be prepared for a shock.
Mark Pliner asked how many people are working
on the show.
It's just me, from research to design, filming
and editing, I'm all on my own.
Of course I have the moral support of my fans,
and my family and friends, whom all motivate
me to make my videos as good as they possibly
can be.
Steve Cancel asked what did I study at University
and what is my day job?
I didn't go to university, it was never a
possibility for me, not because I couldn't,
but because I didn't want to.
Which may come as a surprise from someone
who claims to be so enthralled by knowledge
and facts.
But I have always preferred to do things my
own way, from the moment I left college, I
was determined to do something significant
and most importantly, do something that I
love.
To me University seemed like an impediment
of that goal.
The skills I have learnt have all been self
taught.
So, do I have a job?
Yes, it's called Thoughty2.
Before I started this channel I managed a
small team in the advertising department of
a retail company, but I quit that job to start
Thoughty2, because I wanted to do something
I enjoy and advertising wasn't it.
It was an enormous risk, but I couldn't be
happier doing anything else than making interesting
videos about the weirdest and wackiest topics
I can possibly think of.
And the fact that so many people enjoy watching
my videos is more fulfilling than any day
job I previously had, could have ever offered.
Tim Best asked what was my favourite subject
in school?
My favourite subject was physics.
But I also really enjoyed art, to this day,
I still draw a lot in my spare time.
Mary asked who is my favourite scientist?
There are so many great individuals whom have
shaped the face of science, that I don't believe
one can be called the best or the greatest.
But my personal favourite is Stephen Hawking,
whom despite immense difficulties has pioneered
some of the greatest scientific discoveries
the world has ever known.
Hawking has done incredible work on black
holes over his lifetime, which is a personal
interest of mine.
Billy Stanley asked "How do you think up such
thoughts?
Is it down to research or prior knowledge?".
Well, honestly it's a mix of both, like I
mentioned earlier, I have always had an insatiable
appetite for knowledge and learning.
But I can't for a moment pretend that I already
know every fact that I put into my videos,
an awful lot of research goes into creating
each episode, which I thoroughly enjoy, because
I learn a lot of new things along the way.
Taylor Wyler and Jon asked "Where did you
come up with the name Thoughty2"?.
It's a pun.
The comedy science fiction series The Hitchhiker's
Guide to the Galaxy by Douglas Adams suggests
that the answer to the ultimate question of
life, the universe and everything is simply
42.
This anecdote has has since found it's way
into international geekdom.
And it is a popular joke amongst geeks and
science fiction fans the world over, that
the universally accepted answer to the question
of the meaning of life, the universe and everything
is 42.
Even Google agrees, when you Google "The answer
to life the universe and everything" Google's
calculator will present you with the number
42.
So yes, Kristen Graf, I am secretly saying
And finally Alex, Gambler_182, Milone, Thomas
and Jonathan all asked what's my real name.
My name is Arran, spelt with a double R. Which
is of Scottish origin, the name originates
from the Isle of Arran.
I want to finish by thanking you all for your
support, it really wouldn't be possible without
you, so thank you.
And of course, thanks for the view, subscribe
for more Thoughty2.